bei uns im studio ist jetzt unser
politik chef jan schäfer an diesem so
historisch wichtigen tag für das land
werden gerade die spiel aufstellung
gesehen man muss immer sagen zeitpunkt
jetzt was glaubst du wie sehr werden da
noch der ein oder andere spieler zum
anderen fällt überlaufen wie hitzig wird
diese debatte heute noch hochkochen das
ist ja erst die sogenannte orientierungs
debatte um die es hier geht und das ist
quasi
hat das gerade sehr schön auch noch mal
gezeigt eine spiel aufstellung also wir
befinden uns in den ersten fünf oder
zehn minuten eines 90-minütigen
fußballspiels da geht es dann noch in
den nächsten wochen und monaten
sicherlich hin und her das heißt jetzt
ein abtasten auch erstmal überhaupt für
viele da man sieht es an den reden auch
die gehalten wären einige sind sehr
eindeutig andere sind abwartend und wir
hören ist ja beispielsweise auch von
vielen politikern aus der union die auch
sagen also wir wollen erstmal genau
wissen was sind denn die einzelnen
anträge eigentlich genau was steht da
denn ganz genau drin bisher ist es ja
oft nur eine bekundung man wolle den
antrag so ausformulieren beispielsweise
für eine impfpflicht oder gegen eine
empfiehlt aber die genauen details die
stehe noch gar nicht fest und von daher
würde ich sagen befinden wir uns wenn
wir im fußball modus bleiben vielleicht
in minute fünf in minute sechs und haben
also noch 85 minuten eigentlich vor uns
jetzt hat ja der kanzler hierbei bild
live als er noch nicht ganz kanzler war
olaf scholz diese impfpflicht
angekündigt hat dafür erstmals geworben
hat sich in der frage positioniert
reingeworfen in die debatte hat das
ganze dann dem bundestag den
abgeordneten vor die füße gekehrt wird
gesagt okay aber aus arbeiten müsst ihr
das mittlerweile hat sich die korona
lage die impf lage vor allen dingen in
deutschland etwas verändert wir wissen
dass der impfstoff eben zumindest nach
der zweiten impfung auf omikron nicht so
richtig reagiert das hat die debatte
noch mal verändert und in dieser lage
muss jetzt auch die spd dieses gesetz
organisieren dass das für den kanzler
durchkommt was ist das für ein risiko
für olaf scholz dass diese impfpflicht
möglicherweise für die er geworben hat
am ende scheitert ein extremes risiko
damit steht und fällt am ende auch die
glaubwürdigkeit der ampel regierung
schafft sie es ein gesetz pro
impfpflicht durchzubringen dass am ende
auch vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
standhalten kann sollte es danach zu
klagen vor dem verfassungsgericht kommen
das ist ja ganz entscheidend und es gibt
ein argument das mache ich mir jetzt
einfach mal zu uns kommen von professor
strick und der sagt eine impfpflicht ist
unter anderem aus einem grund
problematisch wir impfen ja jetzt oder
versuchen jetzt mit dem impfstoff den
wir haben gegen die data variante an zu
impfen wir befinden uns aber bereits in
der omicron variante und wir wissen ja
gar nicht welche variante beispielsweise
im herbst dann hier im land grassiert
falls es eine neue variante gibt das
heißt wir impfen eigentlich immer
hinterher und da entsteht ein großes
problem auch ein medizinisches problem
recht fertigungsprobleme zu sagen wir
brauchen eine impfpflicht aber wir sind
eigentlich gar nicht in der lage den
aktuellen standort die aktuelle variante
zu bekämpfen sondern eigentlich immer
nur einen die möglicherweise schon
abgeklungen ist ein riesenproblem also
wir rennen dem ganzen hinterher viele
fragen sich auch ja was ist denn jetzt
man wusste jetzt wochenlang monatelang
nicht okay sie soll irgendwie kommen die
impfpflicht aber irgendwie tut sich
nicht oder etwa doch versuche uns einmal
zu erklären in nicht langweilig das ist
glaubt die herausforderung bei diesem
thema wie genau läuft das ab dass
überhaupt eine impfpflicht kommen kann
in deutschland und wie schnell kann das
gehen welche schritte müssen durchlaufen
werden wenn wir dann ein punkt sind wo
eine orientierungs debatte im bundestag
läuft also ich versuch's ganz schnell
und ganz plastisch zu malen im bundestag
wird debattiert und im bundestag werden
diese anträge gestellt und die
orientierungs debatte heißt eigentlich
erstmal ein marketing-gag kann man auch
sagen man tastet sich erst einmal ab so
und jetzt gibt es bisher drei teams zwei
große ein team das gegen die impfpflicht
ist ein antrag stellen wir ein team das
für die impfpflicht ist die allgemeine
das sind die beiden großen blöcke und du
hast es gerade auch schon gesagt es gibt
noch ein team in der mitte ein
versöhnungs team vielleicht dass beide
ein bisschen zusammen bringen will das
ist das team um den fdp-politiker
ullmann und das sagt eine impfpflicht
für alle ab 50 so irgendwann mutmaßlich
im februar wenn dann auch die experten
gehört wurden werden diese anträge zur
abstimmung gestellt ende februar
vielleicht anfang märz und dann muss
auch noch mal der bundesrat gehört
werden so und könnte man so ist der
fahrplan zumindest inoffiziell bisher in
dem april anfang mitte april zu einer
endgültigen entscheidung über die
impfpflicht kommen so dann ist die frage
wann greift sie denn und eins ist auch
klar wenn die impfpflicht verabschiedet
wird kann man ja nicht sagen am nächsten
tag unter in der nächsten woche geht sie
denn wir wissen wer bisher noch gar
nicht geimpft ist kann ja nicht direkt
zwei spritzen in arm bekommen da braucht
es ein paar wochen zumindest abstand
bedeutet vor einem ersten vor dem ersten
juli erster august würde ich falls es
eine zu einer endlich kommt gar nicht
damit rechnen dass sie umgesetzt werden
kann sie sehen unten rechts karl
lauterbach im bild dem
gesundheitsminister dem wir heute ganz
besonders auf die finger bzw in die
augen schauen vielleicht kommen wir mal
ganz kurz groß drauf schauen ja näher
der
bundesgesundheitsminister der sich auch
relativ früh im dezember für die
einführung einer solchen allgemeinen
impfpflicht ausgesprochen hat der sollte
interessanterweise nicht auf der
regierungsbank noch mal ganz kurz
erklärt warum macht er das also es gibt
die aussage ja auch von olaf scholz dass
man das ganze thema impfpflicht vom
parlament maus angehen möchte so und da
ist es natürlich dann schlecht wenn ein
regierungsmitglied eine rede jetzt hält
sondern will das ganz bewusst ins
parlament geben es war ein fdp vorschlag
zu sagen wir machen das auch nicht
fraktionssondersitzung das als
gewissensentscheidung zu das heißt jeder
egal ob fdp politiker oder grünen
politiker oder unionspolitiker kann sich
frei entscheiden es gibt keinen
sogenannten fraktionszwang und in dieser
logik handelt heute auch karl lauterbach
der sagt nicht als regierungsmitglied
bin ich heute im bundestag sondern ganz
klar als normaler wie heißt es so schön
mdb mitglied des bundestags so sitzen
jetzt also gerade live haben gerade
gesehen socket so ein bisschen mit
seinem stuhl hin und her wir werden ihn
nachher natürlich dann auch am
rednerpult noch sehen gleich wird auch
wolfgang kubicki sprechen das wird noch
mal spannend von der fdp denn er ist
gegen eine impfpflicht ist die partei
noch nicht so richtig eigentlich aber
schauen wir mal auf eine spannende
grafik verzeihung was denken sie wir
haben nämlich eine umfrage gemacht unter
allen deutschen der mitte meinungs-
institut in sage macht in pflicht ja
oder nein und das land ist gespalten das
sieht man auch hier ja sagen
58,5 prozent
jetzt sind wir ganz schnell weiter
gesprungen aber mit wie vielen impfdosen
das ist ja dann auch noch mal das
komplizierte bei der ganzen sache
weswegen sich die in diskussion noch
mehr angefeuert hat was mir sie ist
fragt der moment bei der heißt ist ein
booster booster booster bis in alle
ewigkeit also impfpflicht mit wie vielen
dosen haben wir gefragt mit einer dose
sagen 3,3 prozent mit zwei sagen 13,1
prozent 61,2 prozent sagen na ja also
wenn wir da schon machen dann müssen wir
auch den booster mit einbeziehen und
jetzt geht es um die umsetzung die
durchsetzung dieser impfpflicht und da
sind die deutsche strenge aktuell die
sagen in dieser umfrage auf jeden fall
ins register das braucht man sowieso
bußgelder sagen 60 prozent knapp von
ihnen brauchen wir auch und 29 prozent
sagen sogar notfalls halt mit
polizeikontrollen die impfpflicht
durchsetzen also das ist sind
erstaunliche zahlen dort hat wie wir
aktuell mit dieser impfpflicht umgehen
hier in deutschland